pour le moment les chéris ils sont là
c'est les globules regardez regardez les
avis sont là ils sont partout ils ont
tourné partout cette année aix en
provence anti balance mâcon alors les
chéris on va vous montrer de petites
vidéos mais pour le moment on va faire
une petite démonstration et vous serez
le dimanche 25 mars à paris à l'accord
hôtel arena et je crois qu'ils veulent
offrir deux places de place pour deux
personnes dans le public pour avoir une
chance il faut qu'ils font
j'aimerais qu'on voit comment ils
convoient un petit peu les capacités de
tivo totipotentes et pivotant des idées
géniales et si vous voulez tout est dit
je me place ou un mois d'essai vous
voulez où vous serez alors c'est le plus
dur
catherine ok ça veut dire en fait un
bisou catherine bakaba vdma les bras
mais surtout on peut faire un truc c'est
à dire on va faire pendant 30 secondes
voilà à chaque fois ces cds place pour
l'accord leur hôtel arena d'accord donc
deux +35 +49 9 + 5 14 va 27 passes on
peut gagner 27 passes sur les mets tout
accord on y va kelly a mis le 2 qui peut
faire le 3 qui a offert le 3e mathieu
[Applaudissements]
le casino comme la salle et aux 55e et
moi j'ai essayé aussi non
[Applaudissements]
là aussi
mais non on est lé ga toile twenty place
is well et place toi merci et bravo les
cherry a l'air mais si à la bête
émotions côté ils vont nous faire une
démo regarder chez où je partirai ces
partis pied de guerre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais ouais ouais
ils sont bons ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donnez moi
3 et le tir et quant à tenter de
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
débloquer les prix les plus jeunes
passionnés pour les autres oui bon ok
mais
québec la tête et trois autres espèces
agathe way tournage où c'est vraiment ça
mais relève celles et tunisian d'autres
trotteurs
c'est un texte et jarden enfoncé avec ça
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
06 pas une émission de basket
[Applaudissements]
regardez cette petite vidéo on la laisse
qu'ils sont capables de faire c est donc
et ils seront à bercy en marche mais
chéri merci la bataille ou regarder la
vidéo pendant tout se met en place qui
font des trucs de ouf c'est parti
regardez n'était pas complet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]